The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I guess we might
as well start a minute
early since those of you
who are here are here.
We're coming to the
end of course.
We're deep in chapter 7 now
talking about random walks and
detection theory.
We'll get into martingales
sometime next week.
There are four more lectures
after this one.
The schedule was passed out at
the beginning of the term.
I don't know how I did it, but
I somehow left off the last
Wednesday of class.
The final is going to
be on Wednesday
morning at the ice rink.
I don't know what the
ice rink is like.
It doesn't sound like an ideal
place to take a final, but I
assume they must have desks
there and all that stuff.
We will send out a notice
about that.
This is the last homework set
that you will have to turn in.
We will probably have another
set of practice problems and
problems on--
but not things you
should turn in.
We will try to get solutions
out on them
fairly quickly, also.
So you can do them, but also
look at the answers right
after you do them.
OK, so let's get back
to random walks.
And remember what we were
doing last time.
A random walk, by definition,
you have a sequence of IID
random variables.
You have partial sums of
those random variables.
S sub n is a sum of
the first n of
those IID random variables.
And the sequence of partial sums
S1, S2, S3, and so forth,
that sequence is called
a random walk.
And if you graph the random
walk, it's something which
wanders up and down usually.
And sometimes, if the mean of X
is positive, it wanders off
to infinity.
If the mean of X is negative,
it wanders
off to minus infinity.
If the mean of X is 0, it simply
diffuses somewhat as
time goes on.
And what we're trying to find
that is exactly how do these
things work.
So our focus here is
going to be on
threshold-crossing problems.
Namely, what's the probability
that this random walk is going
to cross some threshold by or at
some particular value of n?
If you have two thresholds,
one above and one below,
what's the probability it's
going to cross the one above?
What's the probability it's
going to cross the one below?
And if it crosses one of these,
when does it cross it?
If it crosses it, how much
of an overshoot is there?
All of those problems just come
in naturally by looking
at a sum of IID random
variables.
But here we're going to be
trying to study them in some
consistent manner looking at the
thresholds particularly.
We've talked a little bit
about two particularly
important applications.
One is [? GG1Qs ?].
And even far more important than
that is this question of
detection, or making decisions,
or hypothesis
testing, all of which
are the same thing.
You remember we did show that
there was at least one
threshold-crossing problem
that was very, very easy.
It's the threshold problem where
the underlying random
variable is binary.
You either go up by 1 or you
go down by 1 on each step.
And the question is, what's the
probability that you will
cross some threshold at
some k greater than 0?
And it turns out that since
you can only go up 1 each
time, the probability of getting
up to some point k is
the probability you
ever got up to 1.
Given that you got up to 1, it's
the probability that you
ever got up to 2.
Given you got up to 2, it's
the probability you
ever got up to 3.
That doesn't mean that you
go directly from 2 to 3.
After you go to 2, you wander
all around, and eventually you
make it up to 3.
If you do, then the question is,
do you ever get from 3 to
4, and so forth.
And we found that the solution
to that problem was p over 1
minus p to the k-th power of p
is less than or equal to 1/2.
And we solved that problem, if
you remember, back when we
were talking about stop when
you're ahead if you're playing
coin tossing with somebody.
And so let's go further and
look particularly at this
problem of detection, and
decisions, and hypothesis
testing, which is really not a
particularly hard problem.
But it's made particularly hard
by statisticians who have
so many special rules, peculiar
cases, and almost
mythology about making
decisions.
And you can imagine why because
as long as you talk
about probability, everybody
knows you're talking about an
abstraction.
As soon as you start talking
about making a decision, it
suddenly becomes real.
I mean, you look at a
bunch of data and
you have to do something.
You look at a bunch of
candidates for a job, you have
to choose one.
That's always very difficult
because you might not choose
the right one.
You might choose a
very poor one.
But you have to do your best.
If you're investing in stocks,
you look at all the statistics
of everything.
And finally you say,
that's where I'm
going to put my money.
Or if you're looking for a job
you say, that's where I'm
going to work, and you
hope that that's
going to work out well.
There are all these situations
where you can evaluate
probabilities until you're
sick in the head.
They don't mean anything.
It's only when you make a
decision and actually do
something with it that it
really means something.
So it becomes important
at this point.
The model we use for this,
since we're studying
probability theory--
well, actually, we're studying
random processes.
But we're really studying
probability theory.
You probably noticed
that by now.
Since we're studying
probability, we study all
these problems in terms of
a probabilistic model.
And in the probabilistic model,
there's a discrete and,
in most cases, binary random
variable, H, which is called
the hypothesis random
variable.
The sample values of H,
you might as well
call them 0 and 1.
That's the easiest things
to call binary things.
They're called the alternative
hypotheses.
They have marginal probabilities
because it's a
probability model.
You have a random variable.
It can only take on the value
0 and 1, so it has to have
probabilities of
being 0 and 1.
Along with that, there
are all sorts of
other random variables.
The situation might be as
complicated as you want.
But since we're making
decisions, we're making
decisions on the basis of some
set of alternatives.
And here, since we're trying
to talk about random walks,
and martingales, and things like
that, also we restrict
our attention to particular
kinds of observations.
And the particular kind of
observation that we restrict
attention to here is a sequence
of random variables,
which we call the observation.
You observe Y1.
You observe Y2.
You observe Y3, and so forth.
In other words, you observe a
sample value of each of those
random variables.
There are a whole sequence
of them.
And we assume, to make life
simple for ourselves, that
each of these are independent,
conditional on the hypothesis.
And they're identically
distributed conditional on the
hypothesis.
That's what this says
right here.
This makes one more assumption
that assumes that these
observations are continuous
random variables.
That doesn't make much
difference, there are just a
few peculiarities that
come in if these are
discrete random variables.
There also a few peculiarities
that come in when they're
continuous.
And there are a lot of
peculiarities that come in
when they're absolutely
arbitrary.
But for the time being, just
imagine each of these are
continuous random variables.
So for each value of n, we
look at n observations.
We can calculate the probability
density that those
observations would occur
conditional on hypothesis 0.
We can find the conditional
probability they could occur
conditional on hypothesis 1.
And since they're IID, that's
equal to this product here.
Excuse me, they are not IID,
they are conditionally ID.
Conditional on the hypothesis.
Namely, the idea is the world
is one way or the world is
another way.
If the world is this way,
then all of these
hypotheses are IID.
You're doing the same experiment
again and again and
again, but it's based on the
same underlying hypothesis.
Or, the underlying hypothesis
is this over here.
You make the number of
observations all based on this
same hypothesis, and you make
as many of these IID
observations conditional
on that
observation as you choose.
And when you're all done,
what do you do?
You have to make
your decision.
OK, so this is a very
simple-minded model of this
very complicated and very
important problem.
But it's close enough to the
truth that we can get a lot of
observations from it.
Now, I spent a lot last time
talking about this.
Spend a lot of time this time
talking about it because when
we use a probability model for
this, when we say that we're
studying probability theory.
And therefore, we're going to
use probability, we have
suddenly allied ourselves
completely with people called
Bayesian statisticians or
Bayesian probabilists.
And we have gone against, turned
our back on people
called Non-Bayesians, or
sometimes classical.
I hate using the word
"classical" because I like the
word "classics." I like the
classics for such an unusual
point of view.
And the unusual point of view
is that we refuse to take a
probability model.
We accept the fact that on all
the observations, all the
observations are
probabilistic.
We assume we have a nice model
for them, which makes sense.
We can do whatever we want
with that model.
We can change the model.
We can do whatever we
want with a model.
But if you once assume that
these two hypotheses that
you're trying to choose between,
that they have a
priori probabilities, then
people get very upset about it
because they say, well,
if what the a priori
probabilities are, why do you
have to do a hypothesis test?
You already understand
everything there is to know
about the problem.
And they feel this
is very strange.
It's not strange because you
use probability models.
You use models to try to
understand certain things
about reality.
And you assume as many
things as you want to
assume about it.
And when you get all done, you
either use all the assumptions
or you don't use them.
What we're going to find today
is that when you use this
assumption of a probability
model, you can answer the
questions that these classical
statisticians go to great
pains to answer.
And you can ask them
very, very simply.
So that after we assume the a
priori probabilities, we can
calculate certain things which
don't depend on those a priori
probabilities.
And therefore, we
know two things.
One, we know that if we
did know the a priori
probabilities, it wouldn't
make any difference.
And two, we know that if we
can estimate the a priori
probabilities, it makes a great
deal of difference.
And three--
and this is the most
important point--
you make 100 observations
of something.
Somebody else says, I don't
believe you, and comes in and
makes another 100
observations.
Somebody else makes another
100 observations.
Now, even if the second person
doesn't believe what the first
person has done, it doesn't make
sense as a scientist to
completely eliminate all of
that from consideration.
Namely, what you would like to
do is say well, since this
person has found such and
such, the a priori
probabilities have changed.
And then I can go on and make
my 100 observations.
I can either make a hypothesis
test based on my 100
observations or I can make a
hypothesis test assuming that
the other person did
their work well.
I can make it based on all
of these observations.
If you try to do that those
two things in a classical
formulation, you run into
a lot of trouble.
If you try to do them in this
probabilistic formulation,
it's all perfectly
straightforward.
Because you can either start
out with a model in which
you're taking 200 observations
or you can start out with a
model in which you take
100 observations.
And then suddenly, the
world changes.
This hypothesis takes on,
perhaps a different value.
You take another hundred
observations.
So you do whatever you want
to within a probabilistic
formulation.
But the other thing is, all of
you that patiently have lived
with this idea of studying
probabilistic
models all term long.
You might as well keep
on living with it.
The fact that we're now
interested in making decisions
should not make you think that
everything you've learned up
until this point is baloney.
And to move from here to
a classical statistical
formulation of the world would
really be saying, I don't
believe in probability theory.
It's that bad.
So here we go.
I'm sorry, we did that.
We were there.
Assume that on the basis of
observing a sample value of
this sequence of observations,
we have to make a decision
about H. We have to choose
H equals 0 or H equals 1.
We have to detect whether
or not H is 1.
When you do this detection, you
would think in the real
world that you've detected
something.
If you've made a decision about
something, that you've
tested a hypothesis and you
found that which is correct.
Not at all.
When you make decisions,
you can make errors.
And the question of what kinds
of errors you're making is a
major part of trying
to make decisions.
I mean, those people who make
decisions and then can't
believe that they might have
made the wrong decision are
the worst kind of fools.
And you see them in politics.
You see them in business.
You see them in academia.
You see them all
over the place.
When you make a decision and
you've made a mistake, you get
some more evidence.
You see that it's a mistake
and you change.
The whole 19th century
was taken up with--
I mean, the scientific community
was driven by
physicists in those days.
And the idea of Newton's
laws was the most
sacred thing they had.
Everybody believed in Newtonian
mechanics in those days.
When quantum mechanics came
along, this wasn't just a
minor perturbation in physics.
This was a most crucial thing.
This said, everything we've
known goes out the window.
We can't rely on anything
anymore.
But the physicists said, OK,
I guess we made a mistake.
We'll make new observations.
We have new observations
that can be made.
We now see that Newtonian
mechanics works over a certain
range of things.
It doesn't work in another
ranges of things.
And they go on and
find new things.
That's the same thing
we do here.
We take these models.
We evaluate our error
probabilities.
And evaluating them, we then
say, well, we've got to go on
and take some more
measurements.
Or we say we're going
to live with it.
But we face the fact that there
are errors involved.
And in doing that, you have to
take a probabilistic model.
If you don't take a
probabilistic model, it's very
hard for you to talk honestly
about what error
probabilities are.
So both ways--
well, I'm preaching
and I'm sorry.
But I've lived for a long time
with many statisticians, many
of whom get into my own
field and who cause a
great deal of trouble.
So the only thing I can do it
urge you all to be cautious
about this.
And to think the matter
through on your own.
I'm not telling you to take
my point of view on it.
I'm telling you, don't take
other people's point of view
without thinking it through.
The probability experiment
here really--
I mean, every probability model
we view in terms of the
real world, as you have this set
of probabilities, a set of
possible events.
You do the experiment.
There's one sample point
that comes out.
And after the one sample point
comes out, then you know what
the result of the
experiment is.
Here, the experiment consists
both of what you normally view
as the experiment.
Namely, taking the
observations.
And it also involves a
choice of hypotheses.
Namely, there's not a correct
hypothesis to start with.
The experiment involves
God throws his dice.
Einstein didn't believe that
God threw dice, but I do.
And after throwing the dice,
one or the other of these
hypotheses turns
out to be true.
All of these observations point
to that or they point to
the other and you
make a decision.
OK, so the experiment consists
both on choosing the
hypothesis and on taking
a whole sequence of
observations.
Now, the other thing to
not forget in this--
because you really have to get
this model in your mind or
you're going to get very
confused with all
the things we do.
The experiment consists
on a whole sequence of
observations, but only one
choice of hypothesis.
Namely, you do the experiment.
There's a hypothesis that
occurs, and there's a whole
sequence of observations which
are all IID conditional on
that particular hypothesis.
So that's the model we're
going to be using.
And now life is quite
simple once we've
explained the model.
We can talk about the
probability that H is equal to
either 0 or 1, conditional
on the
sample point we've observed.
It's equal to the a priori
probability of that hypothesis
times the density of the
observation conditional on the
hypothesis divided by just
a normalization factor.
Namely, the overall probability
of that
observation period, which is the
sum of probability that 0
is a correct hypothesis times
this plus probability that 1
the density given 1.
This denominator here
is a pain in the
neck, as you can see.
But you can avoid ever dealing
with a denominator if you take
this for H equals 0, divide by
this for H equals 1, and then
you have this term divided by
this term all divided by this
term for l equals 1 divided
by the same thing.
So the ratio, the probability
that H equals 0 given y over
the probability that
H is 1 equals y is
just this ratio here.
Now, what's the probability of
error if we make a decision at
this point?
If I've got in this particular
sequence Y, this quantity here
is, in fact, the probability
that hypothesis 0 is correct
in the model that
we have chosen.
So this is the probability that
H is equal to 0 given Y.
If we select 1 under these
conditions, if we select
hypothesis 1, if we make a
decision and say, I'm going to
guess that 1 is the
right decision.
That means that this
is the probability
you've made a mistake.
Because this is the probability
that H is actually
0 rather than 1.
This quantity here is the
probability that you've made a
mistake given that 1 is the
correct hypothesis.
So here we are sitting
here with these
probabilities of error.
We don't have to do any
calculations for them.
Well, you might have to do a
great deal of calculation to
calculate this and to
calculate this.
But otherwise, the whole thing
is just sitting there for you.
So what do you do if you
want to minimize the
probability of error?
This was the probability that
you're going to make an error
if you choose 1.
This is the probability of
error if you choose 0.
We want to minimize the
probability of error and we
see the observation Y, we want
to pick the one of these which
is largest.
And that's all there is to it.
This is the decision rule
that minimizes the
probability of an error.
It's based on knowing
what P0 and P1 is.
But otherwise, probability that
H equals l is the correct
hypothesis given the observation
is probability
that H equals L given Y. We
maximize the a posteriori
probability of choosing
correctly by choosing the
maximum over l of probability
that H equals l given Y.
This choosing directly,
maximizing the a posteriori
probability is called the MAP
rule, Maximum A posteriori
Probability.
You can only solve the MAP
problem if you assume that you
know P0 P1.
We do know P0 and P1 if we've
selected a probability model.
So when we select this
probability model, we've
already assumed what these a
priori probabilities are, so
we now make our observation.
And after making our
observation, we make a decision.
And at that point, we have an a
posteriori probability that
each of the hypotheses
is correct.
Anybody has any issues
with this?
I mean, it looks painfully
simple when you
look at this way.
And if it doesn't look painfully
simple, please ask
now or forever hold your
peace as they say.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So can you explain
how you get the equation?
Can you explain how you
get the equation
on the first line?
PROFESSOR: On the first
line right up here?
Yes, I use Bayes' law.
AUDIENCE: So what is that?
So that's P of A given B is
equal to P of B given A?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I don't quite
see how to--
P of A given B is equal to P
of B given A times P of A
divided by P of A and B.
If you take this over
there then it's--
am I stating Bayes' law
in a funny way?
AUDIENCE: So the thing on
the bottom is P of B?
OK.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: OK, I get it.
PROFESSOR: I mean, I might
not be explained it well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Except if you start
out with P of A given B is
equal to P of B given A times P
of B divided by P of A. This
quantity here is P of Y. So we
have probability that H equals
l times probability of Y given
l divided by the probability
of l to start with.
OK, so you maximize the a
posteriori probability by
choosing the maximum of these.
It's called the MAP rule.
And it doesn't require you to
calculate this quantity, which
is sometimes a mess.
All it requires you to do
is to compare these two
quantities, which means you
have to compare these two
quantities.
AUDIENCE: It's 10 o'clock.
PROFESSOR: Well, excuse me.
Yes.
Yes, I know.
These things become clearer if
you state them in terms of
what you call the likelihood
ratio.
Likelihood ratio only works when
you have two hypotheses.
When you have two hypotheses,
you call the ratio of one of
them to the other one the
likelihood ratio.
Why do I put 0 up here
and 1 down here?
Absolutely no reason at all,
it's just convention.
And unfortunately, it's
a convention that
not everybody follows.
So some people have one
convention and some people
have another convention.
If you want to use the other
convention, just imagine
switching 1 and 1
in your mind.
They're both just
binary numbers.
Then, when you want to look at
this MAP rule, the MAP rule is
choosing the larger of
these two things,
which we had back here.
That's choosing whether this is
larger than this, or vice
versa, which is choosing whether
this ratio here is
greater than the ratio
of P1 to P0.
So that's the same, that's
the same thing.
So the MAP rule is to calculate
the likelihood ratio
for this given observation y.
And if this is greater
than P1 over P0, you
select H equals 0.
If it's less than or equal to
P1 over P0, you select H1.
Why do I put the strict equality
here and the strict
inequality here?
Again, no reason whatsoever.
When you have equality, it
doesn't make any difference
which you choose.
So you could flip a coin.
It's a little easier if you just
say, we're going to do
this under this condition.
So we state condition
this way.
We calculate the likelihood
ratio.
We compare it with
a threshold.
The threshold here
is P1 over P0.
And then we select something.
Why did I put a little
hat over this?
AUDIENCE: Estimation.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: Because it's
an estimation.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: It's an estimation?
PROFESSOR: Well, it's not
really an estimation.
It's a detection.
I mean, estimation you usually
view as being analog.
Detection you usually view
as being digital.
And thanks for bringing
that up because it's
an important point.
But in this model, H is either
0 or 1 in the result of this
experiment.
We don't know which it is.
This is what we've chosen.
So H hat is 0 does not mean
that H itself is 0.
So this is our choice.
It might be wrong or
it might be right.
Many decision rules, including
the most common and the most
sensible, are rules that compare
lambda of y to a fixed
threshold, say, eta, is P1 over
P0, which is independent
of y, which is just
a fixed threshold.
The decision rules then vary
only in the way that you
choose the threshold.
Now, what happens as soon
as I call this eta
instead of P1 over P0?
My test becomes independent of
these a priori probabilities
that statisticians have thought
about for so long.
Namely, after a couple of lines
of fiddling around with
these things, suddenly all
of that has disappeared.
We have a threshold test.
The threshold test says,
take this ratio--
everybody agrees that there's
such a ratio that exists--
and compare it with something.
And if it's bigger than that
something, you choose 0.
If it's less than that
thing, you choose 1.
And that's the end of it.
OK, so we have two questions.
One, do we always want to use a
threshold test or are there
cases where we should
use things other
than a threshold test?
And the second question is, if
we're going to use a threshold
test, where should we
set the threshold?
I mean, there's nothing that
says that you really want to
minimize the probability
of error.
I mean, suppose your test
is to see whether--
I mean, something in
the news today.
I mean, you'd like to take an
experiment to see whether your
nuclear plant is going
to explode or not.
So you come up with
one decision, it's
not going to explode.
Or another decision, you
decide it will explode.
Presumably on the basis of
that decision, you do all
sorts of things.
Do you really want to make
it a maximum a posteriori
probability decision?
No.
You recognize that if it's
going to explode, and you
choose that it's not going to
explode and you don't do
anything, there is a humongous
cost associated with that.
If you decide the other way,
there's a pretty large cost
associated with that also.
But there's not really much
comparison between the two.
But anyway, you want to do
something which takes those
costs into account.
One of the problems in the
homework does that.
It's really almost trivial to
readjust this problem, so that
you set the threshold to
involve the costs also.
So if you have arbitrary costs
in making errors, then you
change the threshold
a little bit.
But you still use a
threshold test.
There's something called maximum
likelihood that people
like for making decisions.
And maximum likelihood
says you calculate
the likelihood ratio.
And if the likelihood
ratio is bigger than
1, you go this way.
If it's less than 1,
you go this way.
It's the MAP test if
the two a priori
probabilities are equal.
But in many cases, you want to
use it whether or not the a
priori probabilities
are equal.
It's a standard test,
and there are many
reasons for using it.
Aside from the fact that the a
priori probabilities might be
chosen that way.
So anyway, that's one
other choice.
When we go a little further
day, we'll talk about a
Neyman-Pearson test.
The Neyman-Pearson test says,
for some reason or other, I
want to make sure that the
probability that my nuclear
plant doesn't blow up is
less than, say, 10
to the minus fifth.
Why 10 to the minus fifth?
Pull it out of the air.
Maybe 10 to the minus sixth,
that point our probabilities
don't make much sense anymore.
But however we choose it, we
choose our test to say, we
can't make the probability of
error under one hypothesis
bigger than some certain amount
alpha than what test
will minimize the probability
of error under the other
hypothesis.
Namely, if I have to get one
thing right, or I have to get
it right almost all the time,
what's the best I can do on
the other alternative?
And that's the Neyman-Pearson
test.
That is a favorite test among
the non-Bayesians because it
doesn't involve the a priori
probabilities anymore.
So it's a nice one
in that way.
But we'll see, we get
it anyway using
a probability model.
OK, let's go back to random
walks just a little bit to see
why we're doing what
we're doing.
The logarithm of the threshold
ratio is logarithm of this
lambda of y.
I'm taking m observations.
I'm putting that in explicitly,
is the sum from N
equals 1 to m of the log of
the individual ratio.
In other words, when you--
under hypothesis 0, if I
calculate the probability of
vector y given H equals 0, I'm
finding the probability of n
things which are IID.
So what I'm going to find this
probability density is taking
the product of the probabilities
of each of the
observations.
Most of you know now that
any time you look at a
probability, which is a product
of observations, what
you'd really like to do is to
take the logarithm of it.
So you're talking about a sum
of things rather than a
product of things because
we all know how to add
independent random variables.
So the log of this likelihood
ratio, which is called the log
likelihood ratio as you might
guess, is just a sum of these
likelihood ratios.
If we look at this for each m
greater than or equal to 1,
then given H equals 0,
it's a random walk.
And given H equals 1, it's
another random walk.
It's the same sequence of sample
values in both cases.
Namely, as an experimentalist,
we're taking these
observations.
We don't know whether H equals
0 or H equals 1 is what the
result of the experiment
is going to be.
But what we do know is we know
what those values are.
We can calculate this sum.
And now, if we condition this
on H equals 0, then this
quantity, which is fixed,
has a particular
probability of occurring.
So this is a random variable
then under the
hypothesis H equals 0.
It's a random variable under
the hypothesis H equals 1.
And this sum of random variables
behaves in a very
different way under these
two hypotheses.
What's going to happen is that
under one hypothesis, the
expected value of this log
likelihood ratio is going to
linearly increase with n.
If we look at it under the other
hypothesis, it's going
to linearly decrease
as we increase n.
And a nifty test at that point
is to say, as soon as it
crosses a threshold up here or
a threshold down here, we're
going to make a decision.
And that's called a sequential
test in that case because you
haven't specified ahead of time,
I'm going to take 100
tests and then make
up my mind.
You've specified that I'm going
to take as many tests as
I need to be relatively sure
that I'm getting the right
decision, which is what
you do in real life.
I mean, there's nothing fancy
about doing sequential tests.
Those are the obvious things to
do, except they're a little
more tricky to talk about using
probability theory.
But anyway, that's where
we're headed.
That's why we're talking about
hypothesis testing.
Because when you look at it in
this formulation, we get a
random walk.
And it gives us a nice example
of when you want to use random
walks crossing a threshold as
a way of making decisions.
OK, so that's why we're doing
what we're doing.
Now, let's go back and look at
threshold tests again, and try
to see how we're going to make
threshold tests, what the
error probabilities will be,
and try to analyze them a
little more than just saying,
well, a MAP test does this.
Because as soon as you see that
a MAP test does this, you
say, well, suppose I use
some other test.
And what am I going to
suffer from that?
What am I going to gain by it?
So it's worthwhile to, instead
of looking at even just
threshold tests, to say,
well, let's look at
any old test at all.
Now, any test means
the following.
I have this probability model.
I've already bludgeoned you into
accepting the fact that's
the probability model we're
going to be looking at.
And we have this--
well, we have the likelihood
ratio, but we don't care about
that for the moment.
But we make this observation.
We got to make a decision.
And our decision is going
to be either 1 or 0.
How do we characterize
that mathematically?
Or how do we calculate it if
we want a computer to make
that decision for us?
The systematic way to do it is
for every possible sequence of
y to say ahead of time to give a
formula, which sequences get
mapped into 1 and which
sequences get mapped into 0.
So we're going to call a set A
the set of sample sequences
that get mapped into
hypothesis 1.
That's the most general binary
hypothesis test you can do.
That includes all
possible ways of
choosing either 1 or 0.
You're forced to hire somebody
or not hire somebody.
You can't get them to work for
you for two weeks, and then
make a decision at that point.
Well, sometimes you
can in this world.
But if it's somebody you really
want and other people
want them, too, then you've got
to decide, I'm going to go
with this person or I'm not
going to go with them.
So under all observations that
you've made, you need some way
to decide which ones make
you go to decision 1.
Which ones make you
go to decision 0.
So we will just say arbitrarily,
there's a set A
of sample sequences that
map into hypothesis 1.
And the error probability for
each hypothesis using test A
is given by-- and we'll just
call Q sub 0 of A--
this is our name for the
error probability.
Have I twisted this up?
No.
Q sub 0 of A is the probability
that I actually choose--
it's the probability that I
choose A given that the
hypothesis is 0.
Q sub 1 of A is the probability
that I choose 1.
Blah, let me start
that over again.
Q0 of A is the probability
that I'm going to choose
hypothesis 1 given that
hypothesis 0 was the correct
hypothesis.
It's the probability that Y is
in A. That means that H hat is
equal to 1 given that
H is actually 0.
So that's the probability we
make an error given the
hypothesis, the correct
hypothesis is 0.
Q1 of A is the probability of
making an error given that the
correct hypothesis is 1.
If I have a priori
probabilities, I'm going back
to assuming a priori
probabilities again.
The probability of error is?
It's P0 times the probability
I make an error given that H
equals zero.
P1 a priori probability
of 1 given that I make
an error given 1.
I add these two up.
I can write it this way.
Don't ask for the time being.
I'll just take the P0 out, so
it's Q0 of A plus P1 over P0
Q1 of A. So that's what I've
called eta times Q1 of A.
For the threshold test based
on eta, the probability of
error is the same thing.
But that A there is an eta.
I hope you can imagine that
quantity there is an eta.
This is an eta.
So it's P0 times Q0 of eta
plus eta times Q1 of eta.
So the eta probability, under
this crazy test that you've
designed, is P0 times
this quantity.
Under the MAP test, probability
of error is this
quantity here.
What do we know about
the MAP test?
It minimizes the error
probability under those a
priori probabilities.
So what we know about it is
that this quantity is less
than or equal to
this quantity.
Take out the P0's and it says
that this quantity is less
than or equal to
this quantity.
Pretty simple.
Let's draw a picture that
shows what that means.
Here's a result that we have.
We know because of maximum a
posteriori probability for the
threshold test that this is less
than or equal to this.
This is the minimum
error probability.
This is the error probability
you get with
whatever test you like.
So let's draw a picture on a
graph where the probability of
error given H equals 1 is
on the horizontal axis.
The probability of error
conditional on H equals 0 is
on this axis.
So I can list the probability
of error for the threshold
test, which sits here.
I can list the probability of
error for this arbitrary test,
which sits here.
And I know that this quantity
is greater than or equal to
this quantity.
So the only thing I have to do
now is to sort out using plain
geometry, why these numbers
are what they are.
This number here is Q0 of eta
plus eta times Q1 of eta.
Here's Q1 of eta.
This distance here
is Q1 of eta.
We have a line of slope minus
eta there that we've drawn.
So this point here is, in fact,
Q0 of eta plus eta times
Q1 of eta .
That's just plain geometry.
This point is Q0 of A plus eta
times Q1 of A. Another line of
slope minus et.
What we've shown is that this is
less than or equal to this.
That's because of
the MAP rule.
This has to be less than
or equal to that.
So what have we shown here?
We've shown that for every test
A you can imagine, when
you draw that test on this
two-dimensional plot of error
probability given H equals 1
versus error probability given
H equals 0.
Every test in the world lies
Northeast of this line here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you say
again exactly what
axis represents what?
PROFESSOR: This axis here
represents the error
probability given that H
equals 1 is the correct
hypothesis.
This axis is the error
probability given that 0 is
the correct hypothesis.
So we've defined Q1 of eta and
Q0 of eta as those two error
probabilities.
Using the threshold test, or
using the MAP test where eta
is equal to P0 over P1.
And this point here is whatever
it happens to be for
any test that you
happen to like.
You might have a supervisor who
wants to hire somebody and
you view that person is a threat
to yourself, so you've
taken all your observations and
you then make a decision.
If the person is any good,
you say, don't hire him.
If the person is good
you say, hire them.
So just the opposite of
what you should do.
But whatever you do, this says
this is less than or equal to
this because of the MAP rule.
And therefore, this point lies
up in that direction
of this line here.
You can do this for any eta that
you want to do it for.
So for every eta that we want
to use, we get some value of
Q0 of eta and Q1 of eta.
These go along here
in some way.
You can do the same
argument again.
For every threshold test, every
point lies Northeast of
the line of slope minus eta
through that threshold test.
We get a whole family of curves
when eta is very big,
the curve of slope minus
eta goes like this.
When eta is very small,
it goes like this.
We just think of ourselves
plotting all these curves,
taking the upper envelope of
them because every test has to
lie Northeast of every
one of those lines.
So we take the upper envelope of
all of these lines, and we
get something that
looks like this.
We call this the error curve.
And this is the upper envelope
of the straight lines of slope
minus eta that go through the
threshold tests at eta.
You get something else
from that, too.
This curve is convex.
Why is the curve convex?
Well, you might like to take the
second derivative of it,
but that's a pain in the neck.
But the fundamental definition
of convexity is that a
one-dimensional curve is convex
if all of its tangents
lie underneath the curve.
That's the way we've
constructed this.
It's the upper envelope of a
bunch of straight lines.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you please
explain, what is u of alpha?
PROFESSOR: U of alpha
is just what I've
called this upper envelope.
This upper envelope
is now a function.
AUDIENCE: What's
the definition?
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: What is
the definition?
PROFESSOR: The definition is
the upper envelope of all
these straight lines.
AUDIENCE: For changing eta?
PROFESSOR: What?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
As eta changes, I get a whole
bunch of these points.
I got a whole bunch
of these points.
I take the upper envelope of all
of these straight lines.
I mean, yes, you'd rather
see an equation.
But if you see an equation
it's terribly ugly.
I mean, you can program
a computer to do this.
as easily as you can
program it to
follow a bunch of equations.
But anyway, I'm not interested
in actually solving for this
curve in particular.
I am particularly interested
in the fact that this upper
envelope is, in fact, a convex
curve and that the threshold
tests lie on the curve.
The other tests lie Northeast
of the curve.
And that's the reason you want
to use threshold tests.
And it has nothing to do with a
priori probabilities at all.
So you see, the thing we've done
is to start out assuming
a priori probabilities.
We've derived this neat result
using a priori probabilities.
But now we have this
error curve.
Well, to give you a better
definition of what u of alpha
is, u of alpha is the error
probability under hypothesis 1
if the error probability under
hypothesis 0 was alpha.
You pick an error probability
here.
You go up to that point here.
There's a threshold
test there.
You read over there.
And at that point, you find the
probability of error given
H equals 1.
AUDIENCE: How do you know
that the threshold
tests lie on the curve?
PROFESSOR: Well, this threshold
test here is
Southwest of all tests.
And therefore, it can't lie
above this upper envelope.
Now, I've cheated you
in one small way.
If you have a discrete test,
what you're going to wind up
with is just a finite set of
these possible points here.
So you're going to wind up with
the upper envelope of a
finite set of straight lines.
So the straight line is
actually going to be--
it's still convex, but it's
piecewise linear.
And it's piecewise linear, and
the threshold tests are at the
points of that curve.
And in between those points,
you don't quite
know what to do.
So since you don't quite know
what to do in between those
points, as far as the maximum a
posteriori probability test
goes, you can reach any one of
those points, sometimes using
one test on one corner of--
I guess it's easier
if I draw it.
And I didn't want to get into
this particularly because it's
a little messier.
So you could have this
kind of curve.
And the notes talk about
this in detail.
So the threshold test correspond
to this point.
This point says always
decide one.
Don't pay any attention to the
tests at all, just say I think
one is the right hypothesis.
I mean, this is the testing
philosophy of people who don't
believe in experimentalism.
They've already made
up their mind.
They look at the results.
They say, that's very
interesting.
And then they say, I'm
going to choose this.
These other points are our
particular threshold tests.
If you want to get error
probabilities in the middle
here, what do you do?
You use a randomized test.
Sometimes you use this.
You flip a coin and choose
whichever one of these you
want to choose.
So what this says is the
Neyman-Pearson test, which is
the test that says pick some
alpha, which is the error
probability under hypothesis
1 that
you're willing to tolerate.
So you pick alpha.
And then it says, minimize the
error probability of the other
kind, so you read over there.
And the Neyman-Pearson test,
what it does is it minimizes
the error probability under
the other hypothesis.
Now, when this curve is
piecewise linear, the
Neyman-Pearson test is not a
threshold test, but it's a
randomized threshold test.
Sometimes when you're at a point
like this, you have to
use this test and this
test sometimes.
For most of the tests that you
deal with, Neyman-Pearson test
is just the threshold
test that's at
that particular point.
Any questions about that?
This is probably one of these
things you have to think about
a little bit.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you say you have
to use this test or this
test, are you talking about
threshold or are you talking
about-- because this is always--
it's either H equals
0 or H equal 1, right?
What do you mean when you say
you have to randomize between
the two tests?
I mean threshold tests--
if I have a finite set of
alternatives, and I'm doing a
threshold test on that finite
set of alternatives, I only
have a finite number
of things I can do.
As I increase the threshold,
I suddenly get to the point
where this ratio of likelihoods
includes one more point.
And then it gets to the point
where it includes one other
point and so forth.
So that what happens is that
this upper envelope is just
the upper envelope of a finite
number of points.
And this upper envelope of a
finite number of points, the
threshold tests are just
the corners there.
So I sometimes have to randomize
between them.
If you don't like
that, ignore it.
Because for most tests you deal
with, almost all books on
statistics that I've ever
seen, it just says the
Neyman-Pearson test looks at the
threshold curve, at this
error curve.
And it chooses accordingly.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You can put the
previous slide back?
You told us that because
of maximum a posteriori
probability, if eta is equal to
P0 divided by P1, then the
probability of error
is minimized.
And so the errors of the
test A are [INAUDIBLE].
But if we start changing eta
from 0 to infinity, it doesn't
have to be anymore.
[INAUDIBLE], which means
the error is
not necessarily minimized.
So the argument doesn't
hold anymore.
PROFESSOR: As I change eta, I'm
changing P1 and P0 also.
In other words, now what I'm
doing is I'm saying, let's
look at this threshold test,
and let's visualize what
happens as I change the a
priori probabilities.
So I'm suddenly becoming a
classical statistician instead
of a Bayesian one.
But I know what the answers
are from looking at the
Bayesian case.
OK, so let's move on.
I mean, we now sort of see
that these tests--
well, one thing we've seen is
when you have to make a
decision under this kind of
probabilistic model we've been
talking about-- namely, two
hypotheses, IID random
variable is conditional
on each hypothesis.
Those hypothesis testing
problems turn
into random walk problems.
We also saw that
the [? GG1Q ?]
when I started looking at when
the system becomes empty, and
how long it takes to start to
fill up again, that problem is
a random walk problem.
So now I want to start to ask
the question, what's the
probability that a random walk
will cross a threshold?
I'm going to apply the
Chernoff bound to it.
You remember the
Chernoff bound?
We talked about it a little
bit back on the
second week of the term.
We were talking about the Markov
inequality and the
Chebyshev inequality.
And we said that the Chernoff
inequality was the same sort
of thing, except it was based
on e to the rZ rather than x
or x squared.
And we talked a little bit
about its properties.
The major thing one uses the
Chernoff bound for is to get
good estimates very, very
far away from the mean.
In other words, good estimates
of probabilities that are
very, very small.
I've grown up using these all
my life because I've been
concerned with error
probabilities in
communication systems.
You typically want error
probabilities that run between
10 to the minus fifth and
10 to the minus eighth.
So you want to look at points
which are quite far away.
I mean, you take a
large number of--
you take a sum of a large number
of variables, which
correspond to a code.
And you look at error
probabilities for this rather
complicated thing.
But you're looking very, very
far away from the mean, and
you're looking at very large
numbers of observations.
So instead of the kinds of
things where we deal with
things like the central limit
theorem where you're trying to
figure out what goes on close
to the mean, here you're
trying to figure out what goes
on very far from the mean.
OK, so what the Chernoff bound
says is that the probability
that a random variable Z is
greater than or equal to some
constant b.
We don't even need sums of
random variables here, it's
just a Chernoff bound is a
bound on the tail of a
distribution.
Is less than or equal to the
moment generating function of
that random variable.
g sub Z of r is the expected
value of e to the rZ.
These generating functions,
you can calculate
them if you want to.
Times e to the minus rb.
This is the Markov inequality
for the random
variable e to the rZ.
And go back and review
chapter 1.
I think it's section
1.43 or something.
It's the section that deals with
the Markov inequality,
the Chebyshev inequality,
and the Chernoff bound.
And as I told you once when we
talked about these things,
Chernoff is still
alive and well.
He's a statistician
at Harvard.
He was somewhat embarrassed by
this inequality becoming so
famous because he did it as sort
of a throw-off thing in a
paper where he was trying to
do something which was much
more mathematically
sophisticated.
And now the poor guy is only
known for this thing that he
views as being trivial.
But what the bound says is the
probability of Z is greater
than or equal to b is
this inequality.
Strangely enough, the
probability that Z is less
than or equal to b is bounded
by the same inequality.
But one of them, r
is bigger than 0.
And the other one,
r is less than 0.
And you have to go back and
read that section to
understand why.
Now, this is most useful when
it's applied to a sum of
random variables.
I don't know of any applications
for it otherwise.
So if the moment-generating
function--
oh, incidentally, also.
When most people talk about
moment-generating functions,
and certainly when people talked
about moment-generating
functions before the 1950s or
so, what they were always
interested in is the fact that
if you take derivatives of the
moment-generating functions,
you generate the moments of
the random variable.
If you take the derivative of
this with respect to r,
evaluate it at r equals 0, you
get the expected value of Z.
If you take the second
derivative evaluated at r
equals 0, you get the
expected value of Z
squared, and so forth.
You can see that by just taking
the derivative of that.
Here, we're looking
at something else.
We're not looking at what goes
on around r equals 0.
We're trying to figure out what
goes on way on the far
tails of these distributions.
So if gX of r is e to the rX,
then e to the e to the r Sn--
Sn is the sum of these
random variables--
is the expected value of the
product of e to the rXi.
Namely, it's e to the r.
Some of Xi.
So that turns into a product.
The expected value of a product
of a finite number of
terms is the product of
the expected value.
So it's gX or r to
the n-th power.
So if I want to write this, now
I'm applying the Chernoff
bound to the random
variable S sub n.
What's the probability that S
sub n is greater than or equal
to n times a?
It's gX to the n of r times
e to the minus rna.
That's what the Chernoff
bound says.
This is the Chernoff bound over
on the other side of the
distribution.
This only makes sense and has
interesting values when a is
bigger than the mean or when
a is less than the mean.
And when r is greater than 0 for
this one and less than 0
for this one.
Now, this is easier to
interpret and it's
easier to work with.
If you take that product of
terms g to the r to the n-th
power and you visualize the
logarithm of g to the X.
Visualize the logarithm of g
to the X, then you get this
quantity up here.
You get the probability that Sn
is greater than or equal to
na is this e to the n times
gamma x of r minus ra.
Gamma is the logarithm of the
moment-generating function.
The logarithm of the
moment-generating function is
always called the
semi-invariant
moment-generating function.
The name is, again, because
people were originally
interested in the
moment-generating properties
of these random variables.
If you sit down and take
the derivatives, I can
probably do it here.
It's simple enough that
I won't get confused.
The derivative with respect to
r of the logarithm of g of r
is first derivative of
r divided by g of r.
And the second derivative
is then the
natural log of g of r.
Taking the derivative of that is
equal to g double prime of
r over g of r squared.
Tell me if I'm making a mistake
here because I usually
do when I do this.
Minus g of r and g prime of r.
Probably divided by
this squared.
Let's see.
Is this right?
Who can take derivatives here?
AUDIENCE: First term doesn't
have a square in it.
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: First term doesn't
have a square in the
denominator.
PROFESSOR: First term?
Yeah.
Oh, the first thing doesn't
have a square.
No, you're right.
AUDIENCE: Second one
doesn't have--
PROFESSOR: And the second
one, let's see.
We have--
we just have g prime
of r squared
divided by g of r squared.
And we evaluate this
at r equals 0.
This term becomes 1.
This term becomes the second
moment x squared bar.
And this term becomes
x bar squared.
And this whole thing becomes the
variance of the moment of
the random variable rather
than the second moment.
All of these terms might be
wrong, but this term is right.
And I'm sure all of you can
rewrite that and evaluate it
at r equals 0.
So that's why it's called
the semi-invariant
moment-generating function.
It doesn't make any difference
for what we're interested in.
The thing that we're interested
in is that this
exponent here--
as you visualize doing this
experiment and taking
additional observations, what
happens is the probability
that you exceed na--
that the n-th sum exceeds n
times some fixed quantity a is
going down exponentially
with [? the a. ?]
Now, is this bound any good?
Well, if you optimize it over
r, It's essentially
exponentially tight.
So, in fact, it is good.
What does it mean to be
exponentially tight?
That's what I don't want
to define carefully.
There's a theorem in the notes
that says what exponentially
tight means.
And it takes you half an hour to
read it because it's being
stated very carefully.
What it says essentially is that
if I take this quantity
here and I subtract--
I add an epsilon to it.
Namely, e to the n times this
quantity minus epsilon.
So I have an e to the
minus n epsilon, see
it sitting in there?
When I take this exponent and I
reduce it just a little bit,
I get a bound that isn't true.
This is greater than
or equal to the
quantity with an epsilon.
In other words, you can't make
an exponent that's any
smaller than this.
You can take coefficients and
play with them, but you can't
make the exponent any smaller.
OK, all of these things you
can do them by pictures.
I know many of you don't like
doing things by pictures.
I keep doing them by pictures
because I keep trying to
convince you that pictures
are more rigorous
than equations are.
At least, many times.
If you want to show that
something is convex, you try
to show that the second
derivative is positive.
That works sometimes and it
doesn't work sometimes.
I mean, it works as a function
is continuous and has a
continuous first derivative.
It doesn't work. otherwise.
When you start taking tangents
of the curve, and you say the
upper envelope of the tangents
to the curve all lie below the
function, then it
works perfectly.
That's what a convex function
is by definition.
How do we derive
all this stuff?
What we're trying to
do is to find--
I mean, this inequality here is
true for all r, for all r
greater than 0 so long as a is
greater than the mean of X.
It's true for all r for which
this moment-generating
function exists.
Moment-generating functions can
sometimes blow up, so they
don't exist everywhere.
So it's true wherever the
moment-generating function exists.
So we like to find the r for
which this bound is tightest.
So what I'm going to do is draw
a picture and show you
where it's tightest in
terms of the picture.
What I've drawn here is
the semi-invariant
moment-generating function.
Why didn't I put that down?
This is gamma of r.
Gamma of r at 0, it's the log
of the moment-generating
function at 0, which is 0.
It's convex.
You take its second
derivative.
Its second derivative at r
equals 0 is pretty easy.
Its second derivative of other
values or r you have to
struggle with it.
But when you struggle a little
bit, it is convex.
If you've got a curve that goes
down like this, then it
goes back up again.
Sometimes goes off
towards infinity.
Might do whatever
it wants to do.
Sometimes at a certain value
of r, it stops existing.
Suppose I take the
simplest random
variable you know about.
You only know two simple
random variables.
One of them is a binary
random variable.
The other one's an exponential
Suppose I take the exponential
random variable with density
alpha times e to the minus
alpha X. Where does this
moment-generating
function exist?
You take alpha and I multiply
it by e to the rX when I
integrate it.
Where does this exist?
I mean, don't bother
to integrate it.
If r is bigger than alpha, this
exponent is bigger than
this exponent.
And this thing takes off
towards infinity.
If r is less than a, the
whole thing goes to 0.
gX of r exists for r less
than alpha in this case.
And in general, if you look at
a moment-generating function,
if the tail of that distribution
function is going
to 0 exponentially, you find the
rate at which it's going
to 0 exponentially.
And that's where the
moment-generating
function cuts off.
It has to cut off.
You can't show a result like
this, which says something is
going to 0, faster than it could
possibly be going to 0.
So we have to have that
kind of result.
But anyway, we draw
this curve.
This is mu sub X of r.
And then we say, how do we
graphically minimize gamma of
r minus r times a?
Well, what I do because I've
done this before and I know
how to do it--
I mean, it's not the kind of
thing where if you sat down
you would immediately
settle on this.
I look at some particular
value of r.
If I take a line of slope gamma
prime of r, that's a
tangent to this curve because
this curve is convex.
So if I take a line through here
of this slope and I look
at where this line hits here,
where does it hit?
It hits at gamma sub X of
r, this point here,
minus gamma X of r--
oh.
Well, what I've done is I've
already optimized the problem.
I'm trying to find the
probability that Sn is greater
than or equal to na.
I'm trying to minimize this
exponent here, gamma
X of r minus ra.
Unfortunately, I really start
out by taking the derivative
of that and setting it equal to
0, which is what you would
all do, too.
When I set the derivative of
this equal to 0, I get gamma
prime of r minus a is equal to
0, which is what this says.
So then we take a line of slope
gamma x of r equals 0.
It's tangent at this
point here.
You look at this point over here
and you get the minimum
value of the gamma X
of r minus r0 a.
So what this says is when you
vary a, you can go through
this maximization tilting
this curve around.
I mean, a determines the slope
of this line here.
If I use a smaller value of
a, the slope is smaller.
It hits in here.
If I take a larger value of a,
it comes in further down and
the exponent gets bigger.
That's not surprising.
I want to find out the
probability that S sub n is
greater than or equal to a.
As I increase a, I expect this
exponent to keep going down as
I make a bigger and bigger
because it's harder and harder
for it to be greater
than or equal to a.
So anyway, when you optimize
this, you get something
exponentially tight.
And this is what
it's equal to.
And I would recommend that you
go back and read the section
of chapter 1, which goes through
all of this in a
little more detail.
Let me go passed that.
Don't want to talk about that.
Well, when I do this
optimization, if what I'm
looking at is the probability
that S sub n is greater than
or equal to some alpha rather
than n times a when I'm do
this optimization and I'm
looking at what happens at
different values of n, it turns
out that when n is very
big, you get something which
is tangent there.
As n gets smaller, you get these
tangents that come down
that comes in to there,
and then it starts
going back out again.
This e to the r star is the
tightest the bound ever gets.
That's the n at which errors
in the hypothesis testing
usually occur.
It's the point at which--
it's the n for which Sn greater
than or equal to alpha
is most likely to occur.
And if you evaluate that for
our friendly binary case
again, X equals 1 or X equals
minus 1, what you find when
you evaluate that point alpha r
star is that r star is equal
to log 1 minus P over P. And our
bound of probability union
of Sn is greater than or equal
to alpha is approximately e to
the minus alpha r star
is 1 minus P over P
to the minus alpha.
I mean, why do I torture
you with this?
Because we solved this problem
at the beginning of the
lecture, remember?
The probability that the sum
S sub n for this binary
experiment is greater than or
equal to k is equal to 1 minus
P over P to the minus k.
That's what it's equal
to exactly.
When I go through all of this
Chernoff bound stuff, I get
the same answer.
Now, this is a much harder way
to do it, but this is a
general way of doing it.
And that's a very specialized
way of doing it.
So we'll talk more about
this next time.